الشاحنات البارحه عده شاحنات دخلت من معبر
باب الهواء الحدودي الى داخل الاراضي
السوريه الى المناطق المنكوبه شمال غربي
سوريا لكنها كانت عده شاحنات حسب الدفاع
المدني فانها كانت معده مسبقا للدخول ضمن
البرنامج الاممي للاغاثه وللمساعدات هنا
شمال غربي سوريا بمعنى انها لا علاقه لها
بمساعدات كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب شمال
غربي سوريا الوضع نحن قضينا في هذه
المنطقه ليله او يوما كاملا ليله امس كانت
صعبه وصعبه للغايه على عشرات العوائل التي
باتت ونامت هنا في العراق هذه السياره هنا
مثلا هذه رايناها منذ الصباح البارحه
عندما اتينا وقد نامت هذه العائله في هذه
السياره كما تشاهدونها على هذا الوضع الذي
هو فيه لم تتحرك ابدا نحن عشنا يوما واحدا
معهم ورايناهم فقط لكن هم قالوا لنا بانهم
هنا منذ وقوع الزلزال ايضا تلك العائله
الاخرى التي تنام التي نامت هنا على هذا
الرصيف ايضا وعلى امتداد هذا الطريق هنالك
عشرات العوائل هنا في ريف حلب وفي ريف
ادلب كما نقل لنا الصوره ايضا من مكان اخر
زميلنا ادهم ابو الحسام من بين من تحت
اشجار الزيتون في ريف حلب في ريف ادلب على
طول الطرق الممتده في هذه المنطقه عشرات
العوائل تنام في الطرقات بعضها حظي بخيمه
هنالك ممن حظي بخيمه شارك عائله اخرى داخل
الخيمه الرجال ناموا في السيارات والنساء
بيتنا
بيتنا داخل الخيمه هنالك مخيم ربما
تشاهدونه الان في الصوره
احدى المنظمات المحليه اقامت ذلك المخيم
واوى بعض العائلات وهذا وهذه الصوره تنطبق
على جميع المناطق هنا في شمال غربي
الاوضاع الانسانيه الان عبد السلام في
غايه السوء والكارثه تزداد حجما مع
اتضاع صوره الدمار واتضاع صوره النزوح
لالاف النازحين في هذه المناطق هذا في شق
الانسان اما في شق الاخر فان الدفاع
المدني بعد ان اعلن امس ان صح التعبير
انتهاء مرحله الصمت اي انتهاء مرحله
استخراج من هم على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاض بالتالي الان بدات مرحله انتشال
الضحايا من تحت الانقاذ الاعداد مرشحه
للزياد وللارتفاع خصوصا هنا في ريف حلب في
منطقه جنديرس وفي منطقه اخرى في ادلب في
منطقه سلقين الكارثه الان هي في شقين
بصوره عامه الشق الاول هو في موضوع الهلع
والفزع لالاف العوائل التي تضررت بيوتها
او التي تخشى العوده الى المنازل جراء
استمرار الهزات الارتداديه اشق الثاني
استمرار عمليات انتشار الضحايا وارتفاع
اعداد الضحايا وعمليات النزوح هنالك الاف
مدنيين كما تشاهدهم وشاهدت قبل قليل بعض
منهم هنا في شمال غربي سوريا مع قله
المساعدات الدفاع المدني المنظمات بشكل
مستمر وبشكل دوري يطالبون رغم ان الوقت قد
تاخر لكنهم يقولون ان تصل هذه المساعدات
متاخره خير من ان لا تصل ابدا لا بد من
عمليات غوث ومن جهود دوليه تغيث مئات الاف
النازحين الذين تضررت بيوتهم نحن لا نتحدث
فقط عن جنديرس او بلده اخرى في ريف ادلب
نحن نتحدث عن عشرات البلدات والقرى التي
دمرت جنديرس هي بلده يبلغ تعداد سكانها
نحو 50 الى 60 الف نسمه وهي مثال
90% من منازلها قد دمر
والبقيه لا تصلح للسكن وهكذا على هذا
المنوال عده بلدات اخرى ايضا في ريف حلب
وفي ريف ادلب
هنا ينتظر المساعدات الدفاع المدني ينتظر
طواقم وكوادر تعينه حتى على الاقل في
استخراج الاموات من تحت الجثث لان هنالك
الكثير من الناس من الذين ينتظرون
اقاربهم حتى تخرج جثثهم من تحت الانقاض
عبد السلام